with us tonight Wallace broker from
Columbia from the lamont-doherty he's
been at Columbia his whole academic
career with a BS from here and a PhD in
geology from here and a name
professorship Newberry professor of
Earth and Environmental Sciences here
he's also Wally his is a delightful
person who really brings clarity to a
lot of these otherwise relatively
obscure earth science issues and he does
that by his basic scale analysis and
knowledge of processes that go on
throughout the planet and I don't want
to do a long introduction here I do i do
want to remember however while I'm doing
this to thank our sponsors who brought
us together for the last several weeks
in a row and that's the hertug
foundation and Roger Herzog has made a
gift to this program that allows us to
have a seminar on global strategies this
is the fourth seminar in a row enforced
four different summers and I was told
just in the hallway that it's the best
one but I haven't been involved in the
other three but we're looking at history
of climate issues on a global scale and
also global governance and trying to
bring the two conversations together and
I think from what I heard we had an
earlier seminar at four o'clock and what
I've heard is that our speaker tonight
has a real skill and talented and
ability to do that Wally broker is known
to have a great climate beast in his
office so have your pet dragon oh it's
outside he's also known for coining in a
way the term global warming and a paper
he wrote and he's also known as the
person that conceived the notion of a
great oceanic conveyor belt of
overturning circulation in the ocean he
wrote how to build a habitable planet
which I think every geoscientist has
read that book was published in nineteen
eighty five and now with a colleague
Charles langmuir he's come out with a
new book called
how to build a habitable planet and it's
a new edition which gives a sense of
where we've come from there I use a lot
of honors and he's just a great guy and
I wanted to introduce him briefly to you
and turn the podium over to Wally broker
he'll speak tonight about carbon dioxide
issues in on a global sense ok I'm going
to be provocative I think you know we're
facing a co2 crisis not just a problem
the reason I say that is that there
seems to be no limit on the amount of
fossil fuels we can get out of the earth
the new drive to correct everything and
get all a natural gas and more petroleum
out has suddenly increased the
inventories of fossil fuels also reduce
the price of them so that it makes it
harder for alternate energies to get a
toehold we've been ever since I've been
involved in this the eighty-five percent
of the energy we use on the planet comes
from carbon burning and fifteen percent
from all the other things and that
hasn't changed of course the alternates
have gone up in parallel with the use of
energy in 1990 as a world we produced 20
billion tons of co2 20 billion tons last
year we produce 32 so and as some of you
read you know we per couple days the co2
Observatory on Hawaii recorded full days
of more than 400 parts per million
we know from ice cores that have
beautifully preserved air bubbles in
them that co2 prior to the Industrial
Revolution was just about 280 parts per
million so we've gone up from 282 400 we
also were going up at about two and a
half parts per million a year so if we
stayed at this level in 25 years we'd be
up another I mean in 10 years would be
up another 25 ppm so and there there's
no indication that the world is going to
come to grips with this problem that's
the sad thing in the US fifty percent of
the people don't believe it's a problem
and so that's an enormous impediment to
getting anything done since politicians
want boats so there's a man here named
Klaus Lackner who I'll speak about quite
a bit he was telling me the other day
that if you look to the future and say
what do we have to do to cut fossil fuel
emissions to the point where co2 stops
it dries not bringing it down just stop
it from going up and he did the
calculation this way he said that
population is going to increase one
percent a year per capita GNP is
probably going to increase three percent
a year and that's what it's been doing
so if that continues that's four percent
a year then if you want to stop co2 from
doubling we have to sort of reduce
emissions six
sent every year that's incredible I mean
to that the amount of money that would
cost is staggering and you know Obama
just said that he wanted to cut
emissions by seventeen percent by the
year twenty twenty so that's seven years
seventeen percent that's just between
two and three percent a year and that'll
never happen I don't think I mean it's
easy to say these things that's very
hard to implement them Kyoto I mean it
was rather modest goals but they weren't
largely weren't achieved so I think that
it's very unlikely that the co2 rise
will be quelled before it reaches double
and if we're unlucky it could triple
there's plenty of fossil fuels to do
that one of the unfortunate things is
that fossil fuels are worth a lot of
money and so if we expect people to
leave them in the ground and not sell
them it's unlikely the Canadian tar
sands we're trying to many people are
trying to stop the Keystone pipeline
which would allow those tar sand sludges
to be sent our refineries in southern
and you know Houston or wherever they
are and but if those tar sands are worth
the trillion dollars are more so if we
don't allow the Keystone pipeline Canada
with this enormous resource will find a
way to ship it to China's
thing and it'll get burned that's the
unfortunate thing is that as long as we
don't put a price on carbon it's going
to be the cheapest source of energy for
a long time and that means that co2 is
going to keep going up okay so what's it
going to do well we're talking just
before about agriculture
agriculturalists say that for every
degree we heat the planet every degree
centigrade grain yields will drop by ten
percent doubling co2 the best estimates
we have from global simulations and
computer models would be between three
and three and a half degrees warming so
that would be thirty five percent
decrease in food / and grain production
if everything else stay equal but co2
itself is going to increase production
somewhat but most people think that it's
not going to compensate plus pests take
a toll on what we grow and the
predictions are from ecologists that
that toll or nagra culture is that toll
is going to go up so it means we'll get
a smaller percentage of the food and no
get it than we do now and they'll get a
greater percentage of I'm very involved
in trying to understand how rainfall
will change in the planet and I think
it's clear that as we heat the planet
more of the rainfall that it's seared so
it won't be that much more total brain
on the planet but it's good to do it's
going to be focused more strongly
more strongly on the tropics and
therefore places that don't need more
rainfall are going to get more and those
are many places that are very short of
water are going to get less so that's
another thing that we have to really
worry about I think sea level which is
often the primary thing people talk
about sure sea level is going to rise
very slowly but it's not the thing
that's going to stab us in the back its
food and the presume an intensification
of storms this is the things that we're
really going to notice so this is sort
of a bleak outlook because if we keep if
if we keep producing more and more co2
every year and this goes on for 50 years
just even if we knew what to do would
probably take 50 years to do it to pay
for we're going to end up with a lot of
co2 in the air so what are our options
we can live with it but i think the
negatives are going to far outweigh the
positives and it's so everybody will
agree that the world was a better place
before we added the seal to them and
after or we could put up something in
the stratosphere that reflected away
sunshine and there is a way to do that
that probably 10 times cheaper than
dealing with the problem itself and that
is to put 32 million tons of so2 into
the stratosphere every year that would
on the average the reflectivity from the
little sulfuric acid droplets that would
be formed would compensate for doubling
of co2 they have to put it up every year
but it turns out if you do the
arithmetic out how much it costs it
would be cheap comparing to change all
of our infrastructure from you know
fossil fuels to whatever I think that's
would be unfortunate if we had to do
that but I think the likelihood that
we'll get into that is rather high not
right away but that things are bad and
we want to cool the planet it's a way to
do it rather quickly and it's going to
be a temptation so so we could cope with
it we could reflect equivalent amount of
sunlight away and I mean you might ask
what are the problems with that well one
big problem is that it isn't going to
return climate to what it was because
I'm the average it will cool the planet
that's the same amount as of warm we
could do that but the geographical
distribution of rainfall and other
things would be different so it would
create a different geography of climate
than we have now and of course some
nations would like that other nations
would you know get very upset about it
so there is there's one other way that
we can go and I think that it's a
reasonable way to go and it will
probably get around to doing it but it's
going to take a while to convince people
that this is something we have to do and
that is we could take co2 back out of
the atmosphere you might say that's
outrageous because the co2 is only
there are only 400 molecules of co2 for
a million molecules of air so it's very
dilute there's a person here at Columbia
in the engineering school named Klaus
Lackner he got his degree in particle
physics in Heidelberg he worked for at
Los Alamos in their theoretical division
for 17 years and then we hired him here
and he's devoted the last 13 years to
figuring out the best way to take co2
out of the air and I'll describe you
know what he would do and he thinks that
it can be done for less than a hundred
dollars a ton that would be very
acceptable because that would only raise
the price let's say of gasoline by
ninety cents a gallon so you know we're
used to a gasoline doing that kind of
changed so that would be something we
could do we might not like it there's a
paper written by people at MIT published
in the Proceedings of the National
Academy that says would cost a thousand
dollars a ton that would be nine dollars
increase on a gallon of gasoline and I
found that more people believe it's
going to be like six hundred dollars a
ton than believe it can be done at a
hundred dollars a ton and therefore
nothing is being done about it okay how
would Lochner do it well you need some
substance that will suck up co2 from the
air and in spacecraft they have sodium
hydroxide or something that they can
bubble the spacecraft air through and
take out the co2 it gets converted to
buy carbonated carbonate ion
in the in the basic solution but it
turns out that to get that stuck back
off because you can't whatever you
absorb it on has to be recycled over and
over again because it would be quite
expensive so you have to then take the
co2 off concentrated liquefy it and pump
it into the ground that's the whole
thing so Lochner is worried about the
first step how do you capture it and
liquefy it and then the other problem is
where to put it once you've done this
and he's a great believer in modular
things he said the reason computer
prices have dropped ordered magnitude is
that they're produced in very large
numbers and they last a finite amount of
time and they replaced and make it
better and better and cheaper in fever
same with automobile same with anything
we make in large numbers so he said we
won't build things like power plants
that last for 50 years we'll we'll build
smaller modules and his ideal size would
be a device that would take one ton of
co2 out of the air per day and he
envisions that dissembled this would fit
in a standard container and that's he's
thinking of making all these in one
place and then shipping them to
someplace else on the earth where they
would be installed because you could
take the co2 out of the air any place on
earth the air mixes rapidly so you can't
make a hole in co2 you could take it all
out in Australia that were you know
seemed like a logical thing to do okay
so what is a ton of day of co2 that's
what 20 automobiles produce here in the
US that means if you wanted to
compensate for the production of co2 by
automobile
you would have to have one of these
devices for a riata mobile well there's
70 I mean one for every 20 automobiles
there are 70 million automobiles on the
planet today so that means you need
three and a half million I mean I'm
giving this is not a little stuff and
then we're going to do something it's
it's big stuff but he says we make I
think 25 million containers every year
we make what 15 million or so
automobiles during world war two we made
an enormous number of airplanes and
tanks in a very short period of time so
if we really had an emergency and
decided we had to start really doing
something big this is something that
could be done whereas if you want to
refit power plants and things like that
which is another way to do part of it
not automobiles not homes but electrical
power plants you could capture the co2
from the stacks but that involves
putting up a device which is comparable
in size and costs of the power plant
itself all of permissions yet to get all
the things whereas Klaus would say his
device may cost thirty percent more per
unit of co2 than taking it out of power
plants but it has this great advantage
you can put these devices where few
people live and the people who live
there would be delighted to have some
way to make a living and so you know in
an industry that did this they wouldn't
tell you to close it down like we do
with him when turbines off Martha's
Vineyard is a no-no because they don't
look nice and so he he has found a
plastic that's embedded with little
chemical islands that does a marvelous
job
picking up co2 and if you can actually
go over those of you who are here for
the summer you go to the 10th floor of
the engineering building and ask for
Alan right Alan right we'll show you how
this is done in a glove box side so this
is just no very small scale that this
plastic picks up co2 like mad and if you
dip it in water all a co2 comes off and
the sites that co2 on are replaced with
water then you put it back in the air
and the water comes off and is replaced
with co2 and it can be cycled over and
over and over and over and over again
without any decrease in efficiency so
but it's not nobody has built a
prototype because our fellow scientists
are different opinions about this for
various reason but since this MIT group
said it would cost thousand dollars a
ton and Klaus as a hundred a lot of
people say well we'll cut it will take
it and call it 500 what 500 is still too
expensive and so what I've been trying
to do is to help Lochner get the money
to build prototypes so here we have the
most important environmental problem the
very serious problem one that you can
make scenarios that would really bring
down civilization I mean we're going to
do things to the planet on a very large
scale maybe that's a small probability
but so is a nuclear exchange of small
probability and yet on air capture the
total amount of money spent in the last
ten years about 25 million dollars so
during that time
we spent military spends with 500
billion dollars a year so they'd spent
ten times five hundred billion to defend
us against God knows what and we're not
doing the same thing and that's because
people are really not convinced that
this is a serious problem I mean some of
us are but unfortunately not a strong
majority I want to see a couple other
things about their capture and then
maybe I'll shut up and you can ask
questions and we're going to let's mean
the ideal thing as we started doing air
capture as soon as possible and that
would alleviate the rise we and we would
build up and eventually we could quell
the rise as we transform our energy
system to from 85-percent fossil fuels
to eighty-five percent renewables but
let's say we don't do that and we
finally reach a time when we're not
using fossil fuels that we replace them
with renewable energy well that's when
you stop raising co tool it's going to
take hundreds of years to go into the
ocean and really that tail will extend
out thousands of years but the big part
of it will go into the ocean but on a
multi century timescale so if we when
this happened let's see where at seven
hundred and fifty parts per million I
mean I would be astounded if the world
didn't say it's the disadvantages of
that enormously outweigh the advantages
we want to go back to what the world
looked like you know now or in eighteen
fifty or something then you could
implement our capture and do it ok so I
would say that if we don't start
doing it during the transition period
we're certainly going to do it
afterwards but you but we don't know how
much it costs if it costs a thousand
dollars a ton then it turns out we'll
probably never do it because that's just
too expensive and that mean a lot of
energy has to go into it and so forth
but there's another thing you can think
of there's a big movement to go to
electrical cars that run on batteries
transportation system that has that's
not a utopia of Transportation those
batteries wear out they cost a lot to
make if you if you do all the arithmetic
it alleviates the production of co2 but
it doesn't eliminate it so one
interesting thing that Lochner pushes is
that if you could pull co2 out of the
air and if you're running the planet on
some other solar energy wind energy
nuclear energy you could then pull co2
out of the air and combine it with
hydrogen that you're makin these power
plants by dissociating oxygen and
hydrogen and water and you could combine
the carbon and the co2 with the hydrogen
and make artificial gasoline which would
mean you'd have a fuel would recycle
completely the co2 would be pulled out
of the air now to go back so it wouldn't
change the amount of co2 in the air and
it would produce water and it would have
no sulfur it would be ideal and of
course nobody's ever going to create a
vehicle it's better than a Toyota is now
I mean with with batteries or hydrogen
so as it should be a big incentive to
see if we can preserve our our
transportation system without loading up
the atmosphere with food
so I think nothing's going to happen for
20 years I mean nothing of significance
we're nibbling and will continue to
nibble and that's helpful you know we're
being more efficient using energy and
we're going in the right direction in
the developed world but meantime the
poor of the world are starting to use
energy in quantities far bigger than
we're saving so energy use is going to
go up and most of that's going to come
from fossil fuels so we've got what we
learned when we were throwing our
ancestors we're throwing garbage in the
street that that could cause lots of
problems and disease and everything and
so we learn to collect garbage and put
it away in a sensible way our our
waterways got badly polluted was sewage
and we bit the bullet and hurt near each
city put in sewage plants and and we've
largely illiterate alleviated that
problem now we're loading the atmosphere
using atmospheres of co2 garbage can and
we just can't do that and so the what's
going to have to happen I think as we
put a price on carbon one way or another
so when you take carbon out of the
ground matter what you're going to do
with it it's ninety nine percent of it
is going to get burned one way or
another you have to pay to take it back
out of the air it's pay to capture
and so the price of getting the carbon
out is built into the price of fuels and
of course that really helps a non fossil
fuel energy because it makes it easier
for them to compete with fossil fuels so
i'll stop here i'll say this is a huge
problem i'm glad i'm going to die soon
or well before the hits the fan but
anybody here in their 20s you're going
to spend the rest of your life concern
with this problem it is not going to go
away it's going to get bigger and bigger
and bigger and it could cause real
trouble on the planet because it's you
know just food alone I'll stop and you
can beat on me and say you know you're
talking about broker and maybe I don't
okay well thanks well we were going to
have people come to the mic if you'd
like to ask the question because we're
taping and the floor is open I was
intrigued by your use of demented
allergies of that we learned to clean
our river ways and get rid of the sewage
we learn to kind of get where the trash
out of the streets and I'm wondering it
seems like one of the benefits of that
is that you can immediately see the
benefits it's a visible tangible kind of
disease we're getting rid of disease
people are getting healthier it's not as
nasty to look at every day we're making
it the environment prettier but it seems
like the analogy kind of breaks down
because if you assume that we could take
the carbon out and do something about
climate change I'm wondering what the
what this what the analogy would be
about the
kind of the benefits that we would see
what would be the tangible kind of
things that we can kind of observe and
say we're actually doing something good
for Humanity as well as ourselves we're
dead right I mean the co2 is much
different because you can't see it it's
a long-term problem I mean the thing you
should think of it what kind of world
are you leaving for your
great-grandchildren and is is that they
may look back and say you all were
really awful there was bad as the Nazis
you were putting co2 in the air and you
knew damn well it was going to make a
lot of trouble yet you kept doing it
because you didn't want to spend the
money to stop it so I mean that's a
harder sell but that's basically the way
to think about it is that the warming
and changes are so slow and we have all
of the climate noise superimposed on it
so we can't say sandy wouldn't have
happened that there were no co2 in the
atmosphere and I mean probably would've
so if it's it's going to be very hard to
do what you do with sewage because you
take sewage away you start to see the
benefits right away there's less tight
for there was this or whatever but I'm a
scientist it's somebody else's problem
to figure out how to sell is to humanity
I can sort of lay out the basic facts
but I can't
i well I said in the meeting before that
would students that I don't think we're
going to come to grips with the problem
until we create an entity of global
entity like the UN but not the UN that
controls carbon and has somewhat
dictatorial powers about regulating
carbon charging for it and so forth
that's very idealistic and it may never
probably won't ever happen but I think
if we're going to really do something to
prevent the worst we should have such an
entity
you said that you think that the biggest
impacts of that are going to harm human
welfare are going to come it with
potential declines in food production
and so I mean if you want to make an
argument for adaptation than should not
be a focus now in boosting production of
foodstuffs or finding ways to you said
that earlier that you didn't think there
would be another Green Revolution but I
mean wouldn't the logic of that position
dictate that we try to find one yeah I
mean it's clear i mean the estimates are
that the increase in co2 is going to
decrease food production and you know
estimates range from doubling of co2
maybe ten percent reduction in food
production grain production to as much
as thirty percent and with an increase
in population that means the per-capita
food goes way down so we are going to
have to adapt because co2 is going to go
up I got I listened to you know I'm not
an agricultural expert I don't really
know you know how to evaluate what
people say about this but I I read well
last spring that Bill Gates had given 25
million dollars to plant physiologist at
Illinois to try to figure out a way to
compensate for this and I got in touch
with him because I figured it forgot
that much money must know what he's
doing and
he gave a rather bleak outlook he's
going to try to jack up photosynthesis
and that's what this money is going to
go to I mean the idea of moving
agriculture somewhere else on the planet
oh that's not going to work I mean our
great grain belts are intended temperate
latitudes and we can you know move them
to cooler places I'm sure didn't know we
can like in the Netherlands they really
intensified agriculture but of course
that often requires more water and water
is going to be you know one of the
problems so I mean that would hit home I
mean if we start to have more serious
global food problems somebody said stop
eating beef okay that's the nice thought
but who's going to do it so if we run
short of grain you could say well if we
if the rich people stop getting beep and
that would help but what's going to
happen they'll have enough money to buy
beef and it will be the poor people on
the planet and suffer because their food
prices will go way up so I mean it's
it's the poor on the planet that are
going to take a beating out all this the
rich will be able to you know
air-conditioned themselves out of it you
might say
is that I answer your question or I'd
say too many words I usually say too
many words my wife says I should be
brevity as a virgin I have a question
about deep sea carbon sequestration and
I was just wondering if there's been any
research on I mean earlier on you
alluded to how there could be some minor
leakages when you're storing it but
either research on that or like in the
event there was an actual like break and
the pipes or something like that would
that have enough to affect sort of
general pH levels in the ocean through
you know global search thermohaline
circulation or well I think if there
were leaks it was mainly get back to the
atmosphere and so it would undo what
you're trying to do and so you might
have to take some co2 out twice so one
of the things we should learn is by
doing pilot experiments it's if we put
the co2 away what does it do I mentioned
before that Statoil has done the only
really a significant experiment in this
regard for 15 16 17 years they've been
taking co2 out of methane that they pump
up from below the North Sea and they
decided rather than pay Norway's carbon
tax and let it go to the air they would
take the co2 out on the platform out on
the North Sea liquefied sent it back
down to a higher level in that sandstone
they've been doing this for 17 years and
since co2 has a different density than
the water that was
the sandstone before in the pores they
can see it seismically so they're going
to see what's happening to it and it's
gradually moving up because the liquid
co2 is less dense than the water in the
aquifer so it tends to migrate up but
it's going very slowly and they done
calculations that it's gradually
dissolving in the water I mean you've
got to get the co2 and water together
and then it was out in the water and
there's infinitely more water down there
than there is co2 and the one that
happens is co take the co2 loaded water
becomes more dense than either liquid
co2 or normal water and it's going to be
like a fountain can't go back down again
before it reaches a shale cap which
would be great impedance to it leaking
but there you know there may be
fractures to the cracks and stuff would
get up and of course 1% leakage is not
trivial because we're going to have to
put a lot of carbon away and so the
amount stored is going to get greater
and greater in that one percent going to
get greater and greater and of course
you have to then pay to put it back but
I think that there are plenty of places
to store co2 where the likelihood of it
coming back is small I'm involved a
little bit I help get this started with
a project in Iceland where we're putting
co2 dissolved in water down into basalt
course Iceland is all the salt and
that's interesting if you can pay for
the water because you could put it and
see what it put it in kind
water once it's in water if the partial
pressure and the water is less than the
confining pressure it has no tendency to
come out plus we find that basalt co 2
reacts very rapidly with the salt and it
dissolves out magnesium and calcium ions
and that makes a co2 into bicarbonate
it's no longer gas so to no longer wants
to come out so it may be that putting it
in basalts will turn out to be a good
way to do it but we're not doing the
research we should do and it would cost
a pittance of what the real thing is
going to cost and it's just a crime that
because Republicans don't like even
think about it Obama is doing very
little and even in his talk there I mean
not doing Derek things he's doing
routine things we should be I mean it
would be nice to have a Manhattan
Project for what to do about co2 and
then really have some very very bright
people figuring out both how to capture
it and how to store it we're not doing
that or we're doing it a very low level
I said maybe I said in the lecture that
the amount of money we spent on air
captured in 10 years is 25 million
dollars nothing I mean compared to what
we spend for AIDS or tuberculosis or
any other problems we have on the planet
they're avoiding this one or just acting
as if it's not going to hurt us
thank you there have been attempts to
see the Antarctic Ocean with iron in
order to create a biological bloom but I
think those tests have failed do you
have an opinion about something as
radical with seeing iron in the ocean I
have very strong opinions about that
which they have a man named Cyrus
Leventhal was head of our biology
department here in Columbia and he used
to tell me that there can i name a paper
written by people who do biological
studies in the ocean that would be at
what we call home run a scientific home
run and I never could do that and then a
man named John Martin came along and
astounded everybody by doing experiments
on the decks of ships that showed that
there's so little iron in ocean water
that if you add a little bit more you
raise productivity and people didn't
believe that and so experiments were
designed where iron was added to patches
water in the ocean that's been done 8 10
12 places and every time it does
increase productivity and it does
increase the export of organic material
down but I was involved early on and you
do models and say what good is this
going to do well the only place that
will do any good is where there's a lot
of unused nitrogen and phosphate because
iron alone won't make plants grow they
need carbon
phosphorus carbons and great abundance
so there's no problem there but and most
probably fifty percent of the ocean that
there's virtually no phosphorus and
nitrogen in the water as fast as it gets
to the plants grab it but in the
Southern Ocean there's a lot of unused
nutrients so that was the idea so
various people have done models that if
you continually fertilized the Southern
Ocean what good would it do well if you
if you poured iron all over the place it
would alleviate more than the prius dust
but maybe five times what the prius does
not it would have an effect would be
small plus you would probably make the
thermocline of the Southern Ocean
anaerobic which would really play hob
with the biological cycles in the
Southern Ocean so whereas I think iron
fertilization was important in glacial
time and drawing the seal two down and
we know it was down I don't think that
that will ever be done in the ocean
there are people who have companies to
do that and they want to get cap and
trade credits for doing that and the
thing is that they do it for a few years
what happens is all the organic material
produced gets eaten in the thermic line
and it gets mixed back up to the surface
and it returns so irons fertilization is
not sending stuff down into the
sediments where it's gone forever the
food chain in the ocean is very
efficient so something like one percent
of the organic material it foot produced
by photosynthesis gets to the deep parts
of the ocean
the organisms all along the way that
that are consuming it so it's not San
Francisco Chronicle or whatever it is
that an article it said John Martin
irons out the co2 problem and he made an
incredible discovery and Cyrus Leventhal
by that time was dead and i glued the
fact that John Martin didn't find it
while Leventhal was alive so I could
tell him there's the home run beautiful
piece of work unfortunately it won't
help us
well I have a question there's this
umbrella term first of all I'm really
glad you said controlling carbon because
people do talk about controlling climate
and that might be a tougher control
problem to control the whole system
rather than one part of it but this
question of an over arching term called
geoengineering which is a kind of a
crude way of subsuming carbon capture
and storage and albedo modification and
now that the National Research Council
was starting a new study what kind of
research how much research how much
should be out of door research on
geoengineering that's the name of their
study and I'd like to get your sense of
you made a compelling case for modern
modular incremental ramped up research
on the carbon capture and maybe we'll
get to the point where it takes off but
what what kind of outdoor
experimentation if any could we promote
on on solar radiation changes and and
should it all be called you engineering
know geoengineering has a bad
connotation I mean and I think that
carbon capture is not really jus
engineering it's garbage people I mean
we don't call garbage removal children
gineering it involves you know big
trucks and so forth and sewage plants
are
big things but albedo modification there
you're really doing fuel engineering and
so I would restrict the terms of that
and say you're trying to with taking co2
your undoing something did with the
albedo modification you're you're you're
changing the system and it's not going
to be a one-to-one reduction that's
going to be complicated and it's going
to have different effects in different
parts of the world so some countries
will say there's a great it helped us
other countries will say it's a disaster
and you can't do it in one place that
these aerosols you could probably load
one hemisphere more heavily than another
but you can't do any better than that
because the stratosphere going to spread
it all around and cross equator might be
a little slower but generally you'll be
doing the whole world and you could fill
in gaps probably if you had a way to add
it you know when when I wrote a paper on
this in 1985 with my friend John
knuckles at Livermore reason I did a
calculation of how much it would cost
and so I called a free port sulphur who
and I asked him you know how much it was
a ton and he said 110 dollars of time it
will be Freeport Louisiana and he said
how much do you want I said 30 melting
nothing from the year they said wow
that's the amount we used to make
sulfuric acid so but that would have
cost then
thing like 10 or 20 to 20 billion
dollars and then I called a Boeing and
asked how much would you know there's
707 I guess they had at that time and I
was going to fly him up to the
stratosphere and it would take us fleet
at 700 747 flying around the clock
loading them up taking them up to
wherever you have to dump it jumping the
so2 and coming back down that would have
been at that time another 20 billion
this is the trillion-dollar problem so
when you look at it that way very
tempting the modifier veto yeah I'm
curious to get the opinion of the author
of how to build a habitable planet what
do you think if a colonization of Mars
as a prospect what was that what do you
think of the colonized possibilities are
calling there's cars in Mars go to
somewhere else I think Mars is
but if I was a terrible the amount of
cost it would be to get people up there
to maintain them you know they just
water up there somewhere but they only
know where it is I mean it would be a
joke I mean it wouldn't be cost
effective let's put it that way I mean
if you're a short of space that you
could manage to do it on the planet
you're going to ship a billion people up
to Mars or something so you'd only do it
as a stunt which is what we did well at
least when we went to the moon we could
bring things back but they're thinking
if men went to Mars they never come back
they couldn't get him back so you'd have
to donate your life and die on Mars and
hope somebody buried you I guess who
anybody loves I I was involved with
biosphere 2 having many people in this
room ever heard of that it was a cult in
Arizona that got 250 million dollars to
build this gigantic green house that was
totally sealed was wonderful thing
people that did it were crazy and I got
involved just because the oxygen was
going down and they wanted to know why
and what to do about it but their idea
was to colonize Mars so you call up John
Allen and he'll give you a different
story he was the the cult blue he did
all the bad things and the cult leader
except he didn't show people or this I
can't resist there's a footnote the
second failure biosphere 2 was the crew
meeting so that the first failure was a
co2 problem right after I've been the
build-up and then the second problem was
the crew mutant need on the second
experiment and broke the air log know
what half one was biochemical and one
was social I didn't break the air lock
especially at vas whose father was a
very very wealthy Texas oilman had four
sons when they got to 21 each son got a
billion dollars daddy said that's it
don't ask me for more money well ed one
of them got captured by this cult and
put in 20 250 million sobia quarter of
his inheritance to build this thing in
Arizona and it was operating and these
people who operated worse been stressed
they were getting I mean I can I know a
lot of the stories about how they spent
the money well he had very conservative
Texas money managers and and there were
like oiled water I mean
you know they were totally different in
every way you know philosophy of life
and so forth so it was a big battle and
eventually the financial people one and
on April first I forget what year now
the sheriff in Arizona moved entities
and through the cult out but the eight
biosphere ians were still in there and
John Allen the Guru was over in Japan
doing something he flew back and he
asked them to come out and they said we
don't want to come out so they stayed in
but they were already adding oxygen
because if you build a close thing like
that you don't have very much air in
there and so bacteria in the soil are
eating up oxygen the plants are
producing it and it's very very
difficult to balance those two and what
happened is they put far too much
organic material to soil so the bacteria
outpaced the photosynthesis and oxygen
went down and they eventually had to
bring in tank trucks of liquid oxygen
and
replace it but we then Columbia I was
headed when they when they kicked the
cult out they hired a company to try to
transition it to some other organization
which eventually became columbia
university but since i was trying to
figure out if this oxygen thing i became
head of science it's a play that's true
I don't know if I should admit that
against you and then Columbia took over
and I was still the head of science and
when Bollinger came in he was astounded
that we were trying to run something
that was that far away and on a fairly
large scale and so I agreed with him
that we should shut it down and Columbia
should pull out because it you know it
wasn't it had a huge potential but we
weren't able to achieve that potential
and so we pulled out I think it costs
Columbia something like 40 million
dollars in total to pull out me to run
it while they had it because a lot of
money that was Michael crow who now is
one of the 10 top presidents of
universities is at Arizona State and
transforming that from a party school
into a pretty good entity you know
research university but he he was able
to hear to go from almost nothing and
intellectual property income to the peak
years
getting 145 million dollars a year and
he was allowed to spend about a third of
that and so some of that went to funding
by a spirit but Columbia to say
something good about it one of our
postdocs agreed to go out there and
start at an educational program and she
did a marvelous job at Columbia and
garnered students who went there this
was a semester immersion program with
field trips and students come back they
would say these are students now that
take that our frontiers course and hated
I'm the same kind of student they loved
it and they thought it was one of the
best semesters at Columbia but people we
couldn't support it with Columbia barn
students weren't enough of them so we
had to get other students and Columbia
tuition is too high and that's what
killed the engine the education program
which was that tragedy to go really good
well I think that should be written up
as how to build a habitable biosphere 2
I haven't been to have any wrote an
article in the GSA today about how you
would do one okay it's a very
interesting thing you probably mean I
know what I would do I would make sure
that that plants produce more oxygen
than the soils and you would have to you
would have to have wooden things in
there if you'd have to cheat in a way
because you'd have to have ingredients
in there to balance that otherwise they
the first year they almost started and
part of it was they grew the wrong plans
the other part was that it was an El
Nino year is very cloudy and so they
didn't get as much sunshine and a cloudy
year they would have grown twenty
percent more and you know that's the
twenty percent in food production can
make a big difference so they changed
the what they grew a Tibetan
agriculturalists advise them on what to
grow and they had no food properly twice
as much as they need it
another question yes the Keystone
pipeline to pump the Tumen or the tar
down through the pipeline you have to
mix it with water and I want I've never
heard anything about the pollution of
the water and the large amount of water
needed to mix with thee or to dilute
with guitar to pump it down is the water
factor an issue environmentally or is it
just the fact that them because it
really just recently a science group has
determined that the the mixture the
diluted mixture will not be any more
damaging to the pipe long term versus
conventional oil being pumped and I so I
just wonder if the water is an issue I
mean it's I mean from an environmental
standpoint it's bad but we had a debate
while i was at Arizona State and I
learned a lot about it from that sort of
discussion and I mean there are issues
like energy independence so if we get
stuff from Canada there are friends and
rather than you know the Arab countries
that you know could turn against us at
any time
the other issue well water is I mean I
mean I don't I don't I've seen one of
the few people have seen the thing but
we have a building called the Gary C
comer to chemical laboratory of the
month and Gary comer took us all several
of us up there fluids around in a small
plane over it and it's a mess you know
they're digging up all this sand and
they and huge equipment you know with
tires that are 15 feet high or something
they put it in conveyor belts and take
it into a heated up get the tower off
sand comes out looking like ordinary
beach sand but they're just tearing up a
huge track I was interested in it
because the reason they can get at that
sand is there was a terrible flood room
through there at the end of glacial time
and ripped away the overburden and so
that now they can just drive around and
pull it out most of that time and is
under I don't know 100 feet of
overburden or something and so they'll
never be able to take it off they'll
have the solution mine it they'll have
to send down hot water and take it off
inside too and so that's a question how
much do they really have they claim they
have a one Saudi Arabia worth of oil but
my view of all is that I don't worry I
mean about I'm worried about co2 it
trumps everything else I think and so it
would be nice if the tar sands would
stay in the ground but let's say we deny
the pipeline what's going to happen
Canadians all haters
because well this this look what Norway
got out of there or there now richest
countries in the world canada could
follow so they would try to build a
pipeline to vancouver or to the Arctic
if the artic opens up it's closer to the
art and they'll find a way to get it to
China and they'll get burned any way we
won't get polluted by it but so I'm glad
and I'm not Obama who has to make a
decision on it because it's not cut and
dry I mean you can make strong arguments
on either side but if you're strictly
environmental i would agree it's it's a
mess there was a thing in the New York
Times that there's a refinery in Detroit
that's been operating since january or
something and they showed a picture of
the sludge that comes out which i never
you know you don't get you know convert
everything you end up with slag like
minds they had what a pile of the three
stories high in two or three city blocks
long just in a few months so you know
what are they going to do with that I
don't know because it pollute the
groundwater this is not
you know not things that I personally
study so i don't really can't say much
more than anybody else
well we're glad you're not Obama too and
what we are glad you're here with us
because of the perspective I think
you've given us by by having this in and
out this very intimate knowledge of
Earth processes down to the chemical
level I think it really speaks well for
for that kind of study for people of any
discipline if you go to go off and be
historians and social scientists I think
you should have some grounding in some
of these Earth processes that you're so
clear on so thank you for thank you for
giving us this overview and a
perspective on co2 send me a letter in
heaven or hell wherever I am and tell me
what really happened in between now and
2070 yeah because a lots going to happen
and i really wish i could see it all
because it's going to be very
complicated how it plays out and maybe
you know the whole thing could be a dud
because it's possible might I won't eat
that much and it's possible be a bloody
disaster because it heats up you know I
think knowing the hertug staff they can
probably arrange those letters to be
sent so thank you for being with us
tonight and I wanna thank you